portland here i just
i i think i said to you last night
why anyone would open a business
in this area i mean why anyone would
open a business almost anywhere at the
moment
is is a pregnant question but why they
would open anything here
is is i mean well it's a question that's
answering yourself
they're not right they're not
and there's no plan b right it
was the sort of you know vibrant
libertarian west that that
fueled the place and if you drive the
businesses out by effectively allowing a
small number of people to demonize
business owners and to inflict arbitrary
damage on them
then what even is you know what are
these states
yeah yeah yeah i i was on my mind i went
the first time i got here i went to a um
a rally protest march i don't know what
you'd call it was the antifa
blm uh which was opposed
to gentrification was one of his
justifications
where the marches marched through
residential areas screaming at
householders telling them that they were
living on stolen land
and that black people used to live in
this area and
they've been pushed out something that
wasn't that evident there were
plenty of black homeowners in the area
in question
not quite sure how happy i'd be if i
were them that i've been woken up in the
evening by people
bull horns telling me things that
weren't true or accurate but
that seemed to be a fairly uh ordinary
evening in this
in this city um
but you know it seems that it seems that
you have activists who are opposed to
all forms of human betterment
um all forms of improvement and
uh actually don't mind the state they've
created
the the sites in downtown portland
seemed to me relevant of nothing so much
as a third world city
where people who haven't been here maybe
interested to know i mean
it's much worse than you expect it's not
just that
it's not just the empty plinths i think
there's one statue left standing which
is a world war ii statue i'm hesitant
about saying that because
they might find it they'll yeah it's a
little high up for their um
their gaze but um the
world war ii statue seems to be the only
thing that they haven't brought down
one is tempted to say oh
[Laughter]
one is tempted to say that um you know
it's it's primarily i think outsiders
think might think it's primarily about
statues but isn't it
it's so many things that have come
together at once it's the fact that
these
sort of history robbed
uh also just you know are inhabited by
homeless people
living in tents with sort of food stalls
hanging around
outside i mean it really it's
post-apocalyptic it seems to me it's
it's something that people should know
about in order to see what happens when
you make this number of mistakes in this
order
well um it seems to me that you're
pointing something out that i think in
some sense only you can point out
um maybe you don't even realize you're
doing it but
because of the way kovid has intersected
with the george floyd protests and riots
and what has happened to portland the
point is in general those who are
reporting on what took place here
are from here and we are held to a
particular absurd
standard where you know i have been
absolutely
diligent about not portraying portland
as on fire
because it isn't but that we have
nightly riots
is um a
reliable fact and it has a very distinct
implication
and the so in some sense you coming here
as a visitor
and seeing it and saying it's actually
worse than you expect when we are
constantly told
if we mention the riots that we are
portraying something false
which is obviously not the case no i
mean
this is this is a maddening hostage
situation
for a population to be in to be told you
know it's not
literally burning down all the time so
how dare you say portland is burning
um i've seen this as you have in
areas before i don't as in this
rhetorical move
oh yeah you know don't why are you
saying things are so bad
bad things continuously happening does
not equal a bad situation
right you know just because you have x
problem every day doesn't mean you have
x problem um i i don't think
there's i i mean like you i've managed
to travel very widely around the world
in my life and it's a
great honor and privilege of my life
but it means that i do have some
reference points
what people in poland are living through
is not normal it's certainly not normal
in a first world city
there are places in the world where i've
seen
similar destitution it's less by choice
than it appears to be here and a certain
element of it
does appear to be by choice um but
you have to go to you know
parts of south africa bits of
india and elsewhere to find the
normalization and acceptance
of homelessness at the level it is
and then you have these extra layers on
top as you say the covert
um layer is is one that seems to strip
everything back and
obviously that my own country is
suffering very deeply from this and the
economic consequences in all of our
countries it's
unfathomable at the moment but but you
have this
this extra virus layer of of people who
think that it is perfectly normal
to engage as a full-time occupation in
assailing the state and any
front face of the state as if it is
a fascist entity which needs to be
pulled down entirely
and the people who say that that's um
[Music]
that some minority or something i've it
it clearly is a minority it's quite a
large minority on occasions clearly in
july and august in the city
it was it was a significant minority
it's dwindled a bit now
but it is not normal for drivers
to to be prevented from going down
streets because they're blocked off by
pseudo-power military groups as is
happening in this city
it's not normal that the police would
not be visible
for hours in center of the city at night
and that instead
militias that are self-appointed
barricade those areas off and the police
don't go
none of this is normal let alone as i
saw the other night uh uh
crowds of antifa activists
trying to
basically storm or something similar a
federal building
in order that well what do they want to
do burn it down
obviously and they get into this
running battle with federal police
which i saw myself and they set fires to
things and
then try to provoke the police to attack
them
and that again i mean i've seen running
battles before i just haven't seen them
in a first world city that's said to be
at peace
um now this is uh i gotta tell you it's
actually quite refined
to have you visit and say this because
we have had um
you know nancy rommelman for example who
uh
used to live here and came back to
report on the situation but
um you are the person farthest afield to
come in and look at it and to the
reality check of just hearing you
describe what it is that we see and what
it is that we are in some sense
stalemated in our ability to even
describe it to the world is very
um heartening by the way one other thing
on that if i may sure
um it's uh it's i mean
clearly those politicians who are in
charge of the portland area feel no
shame and feel no responsibility for the
miseration of the people over whom
they're meant to
govern ordinarily one would try to shame
them but clearly
they were in a in a mechanism where that
that wouldn't work nevertheless i think
it has to be stated
um again i have never been to a place
where it is commonplace and acceptable
for people to graffiti
and put up signs everywhere saying that
a journalist should be murdered
absolutely nowhere nowhere i have been
to
totalitarian countries where journalists
are
at this kind of risk i have been to
closed societies where journalists fear
that they are at such a risk
but i have never been again to a first
world free democratic society
where the local authorities allow
paramilitary organizations to demand the
killing of a journalist for the crime of
reporting
and to have such calls everywhere
in the center of the city and i am not
as people
see in the coming days i post some of
this we'll see i'm not exaggerating this
that i mean we can we can name one but
uh
um but the journalist i'm obviously
thinking of his
name is scrawled over walls and over
monuments in the city
sure i mean he's he's been a guest to
this podcast okay so yeah so andy no
andy now um who's done more than anyone
to report on what
these groups are doing um i knew how
much a risk you'd taken i knew how brave
he'd been
the extent to which he
has been braver than almost all the
journalists from this state put together
in bothering to report what so many
journalists
just think is not worth reporting to
walk through the center city and to see
uh um say on the world war ii monument
on the
massive walls downtown
calls to kill andy no in big letters
stated as such it's not free speech
that is incitement to murder and the
authorities here
don't care about it at all they clearly
don't care about it or they'd have done
something about it but again as i say
ordinarily one would make that point and
hope to shame authorities into doing
something
to for instance take down calls to
murder a journalist
in the city but the authorities here
have let so much go that merely
encouraging the murder of journalists
for the crime of reporting is
is a comparatively minor issue for them
to address
well i want to adjust one thing in what
you said i of course resonate with it
across the board with one exception
which is
i don't think these politicians are
insensitive to shame
i think some of them are in other words
we have a mayoral candidate
who i believe may be insensitive to
shame
but our current mayor i don't believe is
insensitive to shame in fact i believe
he is being
puppeted using his shame it is his
compassion that has been weaponized
against him right
and so in in effect again i think this
comes down to the game
theory which is you have a tiny number
of people
some of whom are shameless who are using
shame as a weapon
and they are arguing they have been set
up by a political
um narrative in which one side is
understood to be
evil literally evil and the other side
is understood to be
the force that holds back evil and so
therefore anything that maps
onto the side that is evil is not
deserving of protection
yes this is the this is exactly the
dynamic that unfolds when one
uh population goes to war against
another it dehumanizes absolutely
and so andy noe falls outside the zone
of protection
yeah of the authority
and this is frightening and i'm i'm i
fear that the comparison you're saying
you've seen these things but you haven't
seen them in a first world city
i think many of us who are paying
attention fear
that we are going to uh square that
circle
by ending up effectively a third world
country
yeah yeah yeah and you're very close to
it in this city
very close to it i mean um uh i went to
a restaurant the other day
cafe um much recommended uh
which uh just the day before two days
before it had
its uh that people had anti-fire
activists
blm actors whatever these ones are now
calling themselves
uh fired uh shots through the windows
uh because the cafe in question has
first responder photos on the walls
that is you know photos of firemen
coming out of flames
um and you know a female
you know cadet in army uniform
it's a cafe run by a black man who
is um
is obviously proud of the fact
that people in this country have
historically and today
put themselves in the front line to
protect the population of the united
states
and this is seen as so reprehensible by
the local
well as i say i would say fascist uh
militia groups
that he is that he has to have that he
has to have the situation
where he's got boarded up windows
because people have fired rounds of live
ammunition
through the windows of his cafe again i
mean
i've seen that in the middle east yeah
okay i've seen people in the middle east
intimidate business owners by firing
live ammunition at their properties
i've never heard of it happening in a
first world city
with the follow-on that the authorities
aren't interested
the authorities which are perfectly
capable of shutting this down yes any
day
of any absolutely this is effectively
being
sanctioned by allowing it to happen yes
[Music]
you